بالنسبة لتيفاني ميلر، كان نزيف الدورة الشهرية الغزير يمثل
مشكلة دائمًا، ولكن منذ حوالي
خمس سنوات، قالت إنها
بدأت تشعر بألم مستمر وأصبح
لا يطاق، كنت أعرف أن هناك شيئًا
خاطئًا، لقد كنت دائمًا أعاني من هذا
الألم الطعني على وجه التحديد على
جانبي الأيسر، أحيانًا أستطيع ذلك  بالكاد تتنفس
بعد رؤية طبيبين مختلفين في واشنطن العاصمة،
تقول ميلر إنها قيل لها إنها من
المحتمل أن تكون مشكلة في الجهاز الهضمي، لكن هذا
التشخيص لم يكن صحيحًا بعد
البحث عن أعراضها عبر الإنترنت،
وجدت ميلر مركزًا لرعاية الأورام الليفية في جامعة نيويورك
لانغون هيلث، وأرى الكثير من النساء.  لم
يدركوا أنهم يقومون بزراعة هذه
الأورام الضخمة من خلال التصوير بالرنين المغناطيسي للحوض،
واكتشفت الدكتورة تارا شيرازي أن ميلر لديها
ثمانية أورام ليفية رحمية، بما في ذلك واحدة
بحجم ثمرة جريب فروت كبيرة تضغط على
أعضائها الداخلية. تريد ميلر إنجاب
الأطفال يومًا ما، لذلك اختارت
إزالة الأورام الليفية.  مما أنقذ
خصوبتها، تقول شيرازيان إن النساء بحاجة إلى
معرفة أن لديهن خيارات لعلاج الأورام الليفية،
كل شيء بدءًا من الأدوية
لتقليل نزيفها أو تقليل
حجم الأورام الليفية إلى الإجراء الذي
يمكن أن يقلص الأورام الليفية بطريقة ما إلى
الجراحة التي يمكنها إزالة الأورام الليفية أو  قم
بإزالة الرحم أو يمكنها
مراقبتهما بعد أسبوعين من الجراحة.
عادت ميلر إلى فعل ما تحبه،
وتقول إنها خالية من الألم منذ ذلك الحين،
إذا كنت تعاني من ألم مزمن مستمر،
فهذا يعني أن جسمك يخبرك بأن هناك
شيئًا ما قد يكون خطأً  دقيقة صحية
أنا آندي جيثر